I hope you had a great holiday it was
nice to be away for about a month please
raise your hand if you're new to this
section but didn't take my 564 last
quarter okay good so this is going to be
a lot of fun this is kind of the quarter
that I've been looking forward to the
most where we get to talk about really
useful applied math dealing with partial
differential equations data analysis all
kinds of cool stuff that we kind of
built up the tools to study in the last
quarter okay
so the basic organization of the class
is roughly the same as before the video
lectures will be online there's a
catalyst discussion board there's a
midterm and a final exam slightly
different than last quarter these are
each going to be equally weighted at 20%
of the grade so it's really a midterm 1
and a midterm 2 after looking at some of
the comments for the course last quarter
one of the consistent comments was that
a little bit more homework and a little
bit more in-depth homework would have
been helpful and so I'm having I know
some of you were wondering who would
possibly write that so I'm going to have
a little bit more homework and a little
bit more in depth but not much okay so
instead of five homeworks we're going to
have 6 each of them are worth 10 percent
of your grade so homeworks total of 60
percents the first one is going to be
due two weeks from now on Friday ok
same deal with the midterm and the final
their take-home cumulative you can treat
them like a qualifying exam the teaching
assistants are Robert and whom in are
you guys in the class can you raise your
hands okay so humans at the back I guess
Roberts not here right now
their office our office hours will be
decided soon my office hours are going
to stay the same did those work sorry is
there anyone that those did not work for
okay if anyone wants to make separate
office hours with me by appointment feel
free to do that let me know I can always
create a second office hours at a time
that's better for other people okay so
the syllabus so last quarter I had a
rough idea of what I wanted to teach you
this quarter I have a slightly better
idea of what I want to teach you so I
have an empty syllabus here broken to
the three basic parts okay so part one
for the first two weeks we're gonna be
talking about complex analysis and if I
remember most of you have not taken a
course in complex variables before if
any of you have would you raise your
hand okay so just a couple so this will
be new and interesting for most of you
and it'll also be pretty aggressive and
pretty fast-paced okay so this is going
to be important complex analysis is
super important for partial differential
equations and analysis but it's going to
be kind of a trick fitting in the stuff
that I think is really important without
telling you too much or too little in
two weeks the main meat of the course is
in part two which is partial
differential equations and transform
methods so this will be about five weeks
in the middle we're going to talk about
Laplace transforms Fourier transforms
and how to solve partial differential
equations every way that I can think of
to tell you in five weeks okay most of
you have seen some PDEs before but we're
gonna go more into depth and really get
to the bottom of a lot of cool math and
this is part three is where I'm
deviating from how this course has been
taught in the past this is my attempt to
make this course more modern and
relevant for your research today most of
the time courses teach you about the
analytic by hand solutions to PD use
which are very useful very important but
I really want you to know how to solve
PDE s on a computer or at least have the
basic understanding of where you would
go to look if you needed to solve PD use
on a computer okay so there's a lot of
great classes around campus like a math
581 582
that go much more into depth in part
three and this is going to be kind of a
teaser to get you primed for that
material in case you want to go farther
into data analysis and numerix okay and
this these methods and data analysis are
very relevant for partial differential
equations but they're also relevant for
everything else you're going to do in
research anytime you have a data set
you're gonna be able to use these
methods okay any questions about the
organization or syllabus or anything
okay good okay that's it for the
computer okay so since you all know me
and we don't have to do the long
introduction I'm gonna jump right into
complex analysis I should probably tell
you when I'm traveling this year and
I'll do that next lecture okay so I'm
gonna be gone maybe three out of the
thirty lectures but I'm going to pre
record them and post them online so that
you can watch the videos okay okay so
complex numbers are not too complicated
we've already looked at this a little
bit but I'm just going to go into a kind
of a review so we always call I an
imaginary number and we call the numbers
we're used to like PI and five real
numbers but real numbers are not really
complete without imaginary numbers okay
so we need complex numbers
and we need complex numbers so that our
mathematical operations like squaring
numbers and having roots of polynomials
are complete okay so we need these
numbers for solutions to polynomials
right it's really weird that we have
this entire branch of math called
algebra but it's not complete if you
don't have complex numbers so for
example if you have x squared plus 1
equals 0 then we have x squared equals
minus 1 and x equals square root of
minus 1 and unless we invent some new
number we're stuck right there's no real
number that's the square root of
negative 1 so we define I equals the
square root of negative 1 okay this is
not new to any of you all of you know
about I and square root of negative 1
and complex numbers it turns out that
these complex numbers I are extremely
important in differential equations ok
partial differential equations and
ordinary differential equations so
remember when we had the spring on a
mass sorry maybe it's a mass on a spring
and you let this system go it oscillates
and dance out and the oscillations came
because the eigen values of our OD e had
a complex eigen value not just a real
eigenvalue you have similar phenomenon
in PDEs and basically whenever we see
oscillations in the real world there is
some kind of phase component or some
imaginary component to some eigenvalue
of some problem ok so any complex number
and we're going to call these complex
numbers Z so x and y are real numbers Z
is a complex number so we can write any
complex number Z
as a sum of real and imaginary parts
okay so Z equals x plus I wife
okay and so this defines a
two-dimensional plane or a coordinate
system where we can write any number any
complex number so we define the complex
plane using this script bold C and you
have your real axis as the x-axis and
your imaginary parts as the y-axis and
any number Z is just a sum of some X
plus I Y okay now in the last quarter we
also saw that there's a very convenient
polar coordinate representation for
these complex numbers where our complex
number has some radius and some angle
fee okay and so this is going to be a
very very useful alternative
representation where we can write x
equals R cosine theta y equals R sine
theta and you have this basic
relationship that Z equals some radius R
times the complex exponential of I theta
and this is probably the most important
formula that I'm going to teach you in
complex analysis everything comes back
like anytime you're dealing with complex
variables chances are it's a good idea
to think about them in these polar
coordinates are e to the I theta this is
going to be very useful to go back to
this form where e to the I theta is
equal to cos theta plus I sine theta
okay this is called Euler's formula e to
the I theta equals KO stata plus I sine
theta if it has a Wheeler's name on it
it's really important
and this is the X part and the y part
and you could get this Euler's formula
by Taylor expanding this exponential
function and plugging in i's eita okay
and you get a real part which is coasts
and an imaginary part which is sine okay
this is basically review I'm gonna go a
little bit slow today and just go over
the basics of complex numbers in
addition and multiplication and give you
some examples of functions that you're
familiar with that we can write as
functions of a complex variable but then
very quickly we're going to be doing
things like taking the derivatives of
these functions and integrating these
functions and getting into some really
interesting math so this is going to be
a little bit slow but but bear with me
okay so you can have addition and
subtraction and addition of subtraction
of complex numbers is exactly the same
as in real numbers so you have z1 plus
or minus z2 you just add the real part
of Z 1 plus Z 2 and that's the new real
part and you add the imaginary part of Z
1 and Z 2 and that's the new imaginary
part so that equals x1 plus x2 plus I
times y1 plus y2 same for subtraction ok
multiplication is pretty simple so if I
have z1 times z2 I can just take the
real plus imaginary form and multiply
them out like you would a polynomial
okay so I'm gonna multiply all four of
these pairs and anytime I see an I times
I I got a negative one right pretty
straightforward so x1 times x2 and then
the other real part is the I squared
times y1 y2 which is a minus y1 y2 and
then my cross terms both have an eye on
them so plus I times x1 y2 plus x2 y1
that make sense right you just multiply
this out collect all the real parts on
one side all the imaginary parts on the
other that's basically the name of the
game is keep the real parts and the
imaginary parts separate yep division is
a little bit more complicated but not
much so if I have Z 1 divided by Z 2
then I'm gonna do the same thing I'm
going to take X 1 plus iy 1 divided by X
2 plus iy 2 now how many of you remember
how to get rid of a complex number in
the denominator multiply top and bottom
by the complex conjugates so there's a
rule so Z bar is the complex conjugate
and that's equal to X minus iy so
instead of so if Z equals x plus iy then
z bar equals X minus iy that's the
complex conjugate really really
important and it's true that Z times Z
bar is always real okay you can just
multiply these out and figure out for
yourself that the cut the cross terms
with an I cancel and you're left with x
squared plus y squared which is the
length of Z okay squared so we're going
to multiply this top and bottom by Z 2
conjugate
and we get Z 1 times Z 2 bar divided by
the length of Z 2 squared
okay this multiplication is just the
same as this formula up here and this is
a real number the length of Z 2 squared
R squared if you like okay all of this
is easier in polar coordinates so for
example Z 1 times Z 2 in polar
coordinates is just R 1 R 2 e to the I
theta 1 e to the I theta 2 which is R 1
R 2 e to the I theta 1 plus theta 2 much
simpler to do multiplication in polar
coordinates you multiply the radii and
you add the angles and the same thing
with division Z 1 divided by Z 2 is just
R 1 over R 2 e to the I theta 1 minus
theta 2 much much much simpler in polar
coordinates and I'm going to draw a
picture because I like these pictures a
lot better than algebra ok so let's see
so let's say that I have two vectors I
have Z 1 and Z 2 and they have angles
theta 1 and theta 2 and radii R 1 and R
2 like above so the product of these I
just take this radius times the 3 dias
the lengths multiply and I add up theta
1 plus theta 2 so I get something that
is theta 1 plus theta 2 with a radius
that's r1 times r2 and that's the
product z1 times z2 ok so there's a very
nice geometric interpretation of matrix
multiplication of multiplication you
just multiply their radii add their
angles okay all right good so now are
there any questions before I get into
complex functions
nope okay so now I want to tell you
about functions of a complex variable
I've already shown you one function the
complex conjugates and I guess e to the
I theta is also a function of a complex
variable but almost every function you
can think of can be written as a
function of Z instead of just a function
of a real X and this is going to be a
really important concept okay so we have
functions of Z and what we're gonna find
out towards the end of the lecture today
and in tomorrow Wednesday's lecture is
that simple functions that were used to
of real numbers might become really
weird or nasty when we give them complex
variable arguments ok so there's lots of
funny weird things that can happen in
the complex plane that don't happen for
real numbers ok so I'm just going to go
down the list so functions that you're
used to that you can also write down in
complex plane are things like powers of
Z right polynomials you can write down
polynomials in a complex variable so
this would be something like our coasts
theta plus I sine theta taken to the
power n right which is R to the N cosine
a plus I sine theta to the power n so
this is a power function you can have
polynomials so I can have the sum from k
equals 0 to n of some number times e to
the K this number could be a complex
number this could be square root of
negative 1 times e to the K ok so I can
have complex polynomials built out of
these complex monomials
I can have complex rational functions so
I can have a ratio of two polynomials
okay so I can have a polynomial divided
by a polynomial a rational function
we're used to those in real numbers same
thing in complex numbers except these
can get really really strange in the
complex plane I can also have things
like Taylor series so these are finite
polynomials right but I could have a sum
K equals 0 to infinity I'm a K Z minus Z
naught to the power K I could have a
Taylor series and you have the same
basic concerns with complex value Taylor
series that you do with the real value
Taylor series like does this converge is
it actually defined can I take its
derivative is it smooth things like that
so you can have Taylor series and the
Taylor series is only convergent if it
passes the ratio test okay so if l
equals the limit as K goes to infinity
of a k plus 1 divided by a K exists and
when I say exists I mean this L is a
finite number it's not infinity 5 or 10
or 0.1 or 0 ok so if this limit of 1
larger coefficient divided by the
previous coefficient as K goes to
infinity if that limit exists then this
Taylor series passes the ratio test and
it converges and it has a radius a
radius of convergence given by 1 over L
okay so not all series that you can
write down not all numbers a K will give
you a convergent Taylor series but they
will converge and it will be a nice
well-defined function if this ratio test
exists and then you'll have this radius
of convergence so these are some
examples of functions that we're used to
seeing I'll write down some other
functions in a minute like e to the Z
and sine of Z and cosine of Z but maybe
I'll just give you an example of this
ratio test first so this is something
you've all done in calculus right ratio
tests to see if Taylor series converge
so let's see if this exponential
function has a convergent Taylor series
okay so e to the Z is defined as the sum
from k equals 0 to infinity of 1 over K
factorial times Z to the power K right
this is just the definition of
exponential and instead of plugging in a
real number X I'm plugging in a complex
number Z and if you plugged in I theta
for example and expanded this out you'd
get cos theta plus I sine theta the odd
terms would be imaginary and the even
terms would be real okay so let's check
convergence okay so let's do this limit
L is the limit as K goes to infinity of
what are the coefficients that I'm
taking what's a k plus 1 1 over k plus 1
factorial and what's a K 1 over K
factorial so so this is a K plus 1 and
this is 1 over a K and so that's the
limit
of right all of these k factorials
cancel out and I'm just left with one
over k plus one and in the limit as K
goes to infinity this equals zero so l
equals zero and my radius of convergence
is infinite right 1 over L so this is
the kind of thing that we're used to
from regular calculus and it still holds
for functions of a complex variable we
still want to have Taylor series we
still want to be able to take
derivatives we still want to be able to
write things as convergent power series
expansions
okay now knowing each of the Z equals
this convergent power series and knowing
oilers formula which is e to the I theta
equals Coast's theta plus I sine theta
we can revisit our power Z to the N and
we can actually find a nice simplified
expression for this I don't like this
coasts plus I sine theta to the power n
because if I wanted to evaluate this for
a large n I'd have to do a huge binomial
expansion right I would get like Coast
to the n plus n coast to the N minus 1
sine plus some other horrible mess right
it would be this nasty nasty thing but
using Euler's formula you can simplify
this dramatically so if I have Z to the
N equals r e to the I theta to the nth
power this equals R to the n times e to
the I and theta right if I take e to the
I theta and I multiply it by itself n
times that's I say two plus I theta plus
I
theta and x gives me each of the I and
theta okay
and that equals R to the power n times
Coase and theta plus I sine and theta
now this is a really simple formula it's
this is exactly what this nasty
expression equals okay so if you expand
it all this out you get a bunch of stuff
magically factoring into these two very
simple expressions cosine theta plus I
sine n theta it's a simple formula but
it's one of my favorites because it's so
illustrates why you want to be working
in polar coordinates and this is called
Bob's formula not quite as important as
Euler but still important and you can
draw the same picture here this is just
this is just like the picture for a
complex number multiplication where in
the complex plane if I have if I have Z
given by R + theta then Z squared is
going to be given by R squared + 2 theta
and Z cubed is going to be given by our
cube + 3 theta and so on and so forth ok
so taking the power of a complex number
is really simple you just take its
radius to that power and then you take
that power times its angle ok n times
its angle
okay any questions about this complex
geometry or the convergent Taylor series
we're gonna be extremely interested in
functions that have convergent Taylor
series we're gonna give those functions
a special name we're gonna call them
analytic functions and those are gonna
be the functions where we can do basic
calculus we can do derivatives and
integrals and all of the things we're
used to from calculus for functions that
have these convergent Taylor series and
that's all I'm going to talk about on
Wednesday and Friday is how to take and
do calculus on special functions that
have convergent Taylor series okay okay
but that's for Wednesday and Friday so
I'm going to keep telling you about more
functions
how many of you have worked with
hyperbolic functions before okay so I
was a math major before I started doing
engineering in grad school and so this
equivalent course in my grad school is
the first time I had ever seen a
hyperbolic function in real life but
they turned out to be pretty useful so
you have hyperbolic functions I'm the
great thing about hyperbolic functions
and actually trigonometry gonna metric
functions for that matter is that they
actually make a lot more sense in the
complex plane so there's a lot of things
that you can do with hyperbolic
functions that only make sense when you
think about them in terms of complex
numbers so we're gonna say sine of sorry
sine H of Z or Cinch of Z is e to the Z
minus e to the minus Z divided by 2 I'm
just defining this that's we call this
cinch like it's easy it's a cinch cosh
of Z the hyperbolic cosine of Z is e to
the Z plus e to the minus C divided by 2
any other meanings for the word cosh
anyone knows oh come on somebody you
have to know another meaning for cosh
not Akash B'gosh but so a billy club in
England is called a cosh so you can get
beat with a cosh okay and then you have
tan tan chubs e is just the ratio of
these two so it's e to the Z minus e to
the minus Z divided by e to the Z plus e
to the minus Z equals okay what I'm
going to do is I'm going to multiply top
and bottom by each of the Z so I'm going
to get you to the 2z minus 1 divided by
e to the 2z plus 1 so that's tan skosh
and cinch okay
and because they're built on these
Exponential's we can plug in any complex
number we like and they're totally well
defined ok same thing for trigonometric
functions so you can have sine of Z
equals e to the i z minus e to the minus
i Z divided by 2 I and you have regular
cosine of Z equals e to the I Z plus e
to the minus i Z / - not - I just - ok
so sine and cosine now there's some
interesting things here if you plug in a
real number for sine it's a little weird
that these sines and cosines have
imaginary numbers in them in the
formulation right but if you plug in a
real number into Z in either of these
two expressions then the imaginary parts
of these cancel and the real parts stay
together and so these are real valued
for real valued inputs ok normally sine
and cosine can only be between negative
1 and 1 that's not true for complex Z so
you can have sine of let's see I haven't
here so you can have sign of 10 I let's
just try this
so sign of 10 I is equal to let's take
the absolute value this is equal to so
I'm going to plug 10 i into i z and - i
Z and I'm gonna get e to the minus 10
minus e to the plus 10 divided by 2 this
is a huge number this is bigger than
10,000 right e to the 10 is a really
really really big number so sine of 10 I
is huge okay has a really really large
radius you can have sines and cosines
that are much larger than plus or minus
1
and they're also going to be complex
like there's probably an eye in here
okay good there's some really important
identities I want you to know and I'm
probably going to put these on the first
homework so you will be able to work
these out so some identities are I times
sine Z equals Cinch of isay you'll have
to work out the math but it's not
implausible that those would be related
similarly coasts of Z equals cosh of I Z
+ sine of eyes Z equals eye
Cinch of Z Coase I see gosh of Z I post
all of my notes on line so you don't
strictly speaking have to write all this
down if you don't want and then there's
some really nice relationships to the
function e so e to the Z equals cosh of
Z plus cinch
of Z and it also equals coasts of eysie
minus I sine of AI Z so all of these
functions are related hyperbolic
functions trigonometric functions and
the exponential function all intimately
related and I would encourage you to
actually kind of figure out why all of
these identities are true and really
work it out because it's really
important to be comfortable with these
different expressions for the things
we're gonna do later okay there's a lot
of solutions of partial differential
equations that require you to be able to
work with these types of functions and
these types of functions for general
complex variables Z okay good I have 15
minutes left so that's just enough time
to tell you about some weird things that
can happen so everything I told you so
far has been relatively straightforward
okay it's not too much of a stretch from
what we know about real numbers to think
about these things then now we're gonna
start talking about some of the bad and
strange things that can happen in the
complex plane so let's look at the
complex logarithm
okay we're gonna use the complex log a
whole lot and it's going to be really
really important so this is kind of
important so we're going to define log
as the inverse function of exponential
of e to the okay so that's where we're
gonna start from and we're gonna figure
out what are the properties of the
logarithm if it is the inverse of the
exponential function so we're gonna let
Z equal X plus iy and we're gonna let W
equal u plus IV and we're gonna say W
equals log of Z we're defining W to be
the log of Z and we're going to define
what this log function means we're gonna
say that means that Z equals e to the W
right this is what it means for log to
be the inverse of the exponential
function is that if W equals log Z then
Z equals e to the W okay now we're gonna
write this out kind of long long ways
I'm gonna start with this expression so
I'm going to say X plus iy is going to
equal e to the U plus IV okay now I can
write that as e to the U times e to the
IV no problem and I can also write that
as e to the U which is a real number
times Coast's V plus I sine P remember
both U and V are real numbers W is the
complex number so these are all
equivalent ways of writing X plus iy and
so based on this expression I'm going to
derive things that have to be true about
U and V okay so for example x equals e
to the U cosine V
and y equals e to the U sine V okay and
so what that tells me is that x squared
plus y squared is equal to e to the two
u times coast squared plus sine squared
which is one and so what that tells me
is that each of the u equals my radius R
it equals square root of x squared plus
y squared okay so that makes sense I'm
just I'm just figuring out what has to
be true about U and V if X plus iy
equals this thing one of those
properties is that e to the U has to be
equal to the length of Z the radius the
length of this z function which means u
equals the regular old real valued log
of the length of Z right this is the
this is a real number
length of Z is a real number log of that
is also a real number okay now let's
figure out what has to be true of V
so what has to be true of you what is
the function what is the variable V look
like in that expression in this
expression what is V look like well it
looks a lot like an angle right eetu the
I V it looks a lot like an angle and so
we have V equals theta which is the
angle of my function my variable to see
right angle of Z so I have these two
expressions now what's interesting is
that if I took this angle and I added
2pi to it I get the same angle right I
could add 4 pi 6 pi 8 pi it doesn't
matter and so it turns out that this V
actually has multiple values that
satisfy this expression okay so the log
so what we're gonna say is theta plus 2
and pi also works and so this entire big
log function log Z remember log Z equals
u plus IV
so u is the log of the length of Z plus
I times V which is theta plus 2 pi n
where n can be any integer
the set of all integers okay so this is
really really strange what this means is
that our simple logarithm function that
we've been using for years is much more
complicated in the complex plane so in
the complex plane our log function has a
real part this is U which is just the
log of the radius of my complex number
and it has an imaginary part V which is
the phase angle of my complex number Z
plus any multiple of two pi that you
like so what this means is that this is
a multivalued function which is really
strange we're not used to that right
we're not used to our functions being
multi-value necessarily so this Big Z do
you all know this symbol just means the
set of all integers it's from the German
word zahlen which means numbers little
epsilon here means n is an element of
the integers so I'm going to use this
notation a lot and we say for N equals
zero we have the principal value okay so
although there are infinitely many
solutions to this log Z there's one
special solution when N equals 0 and we
call that the principal value okay this
is a little strange so this function log
is now slightly unsettling there's
something weird happening and it's going
to turn out to be really important later
on that you can get these different
multi valued functions so I'm just going
to draw a picture to illustrate what's
happening here
before we end okay so this is the W
plane this is the Z plane and I have
some variable Z some complex number
which has an R and a theta okay I have a
complex number and we can take the log
of that complex number and the real part
U is equal to R okay but the imaginary
part V is equal to theta or theta plus 2
pi or theta minus 2 pi these are all
solutions to log of Z so if I took the
exponential of any one of these points I
would get this exact z value okay so
that's what this long fun function
formula means is that the real part of
my log is just log of the radius this is
log of R and the imaginary part is just
the angle of my complex where at
variable Z plus 2 pi plus 4 PI plus 6 PI
and so on
so we're going to use this basic idea
that I can have multiple values to do
things like look at the cubed roots of
one all of the cubed roots of one in the
complex plane there's three of them or
the cubed roots of negative one in the
complex plane so next lecture on
Wednesday we're gonna get kind of a more
concrete example of this type of
behavior where you have multi valued
functions for something that's really
simple and easy to understand which is
taking roots of the number one okay so
this was a bit of the slow lecture next
lecture we're gonna get into how to take
the derivatives of complex valued
functions when we can and cannot do it
the third lecture we're going to be
doing complex integrals contour
integrals and path integrals and then in
the second week we're going to be
essentially learning to integrate all
kinds of nasty functions that you would
have never dreamt that you could
integrate before and they're all going
to help us with PDE s and Fourier
transforms and Laplace transforms okay
I'll see you on Wednesday